and once I was seven years old my daddy
told me a whole bunch of lies that he
thought were funny and now I think those
lies should be told
[Music]
he used to try to trick me when he was
in the kitchen he told me all my
vegetables they tasted just like chicken
he once told my sister that I was
allergic to cats just so that we didn't
have to have a [__] cat that's true I
did yeah yo why do I have to have a cat
I don't like cats [__] that this is my
house too I'm not getting a [__] cat
yeah I remember she asked me she goes I
got a cat I go no your brother's
allergic and he was like I am I was like
you are now yeah
yeah you know we found out a couple
years later I was really allergic to
cats yeah
we manifested it it was great
yeah
my daddy used to tell me whenever I
wanted ice cream that the truck would
only play its music when it's empty
that's true too I did that also hey hey
I had a bone to pick with you real quick
what the f what is going on why was that
ice cream truck always empty but why did
every other kid on the Block have ice
cream like what
you raise kids without money you get
tired of saying you don't have money so
it's just easier to be like no it only
plays music when it's empty and he was
like oh okay
I didn't know any better but you know I
dated a girl in high school uh probably
around 16 and we were outside my house
and the ice cream truck came by
and it was playing its music
I put my [__] wallet away I was like
well no ice cream today and she looked
at me like she was baffled and she
looked at me she goes
what and I said yeah
my dad always told me that if the truck
was playing his music it was empty so we
could never get ice cream
she's doing what some of you guys are
doing right now which is laughing
directly at me
and she looked me dead in the face and
she said your dad [__] you for your
entire childhood
[Music]
I was I was baffled I was like what do
you mean
and she said the ice cream truck only
plays music when it's full of ice cream
[Music]
so that anger from that memory inspired
this next verse
you haven't heard this
[Music]
and soon he'll be 60 years old and yeah
wait a second
I don't like your tone frankly I don't
like
I don't like the subject matter I don't
like any of this part of this song at
all you don't want to hear the rest of
it but I know they do so why don't you
yeah why don't you run it back from the
top pops thanks
yeah I said it
and soon he'll be 60 years old and yeah
I think that's really old and really
finally start wearing skinny jeans
look I I know eventually you have to
stop I would like to know where that age
is personally who invited you on I
appreciate y'all I'll see you guys thank
you so much